[Musik]
am mittwoch feiert die karte 65 jähriges
bestehen mit einem festakt wird dieses
jubiläum in der maria theresien kaserne
gefeiert dabei werden 200 rekruten
angelobt tradition ist dabei lebendig
wie eh und je ich habe es gerade in
diesen bewegten zeiten wichtig sich auf
werte zu besinnen und
traditionen auch zu leben das ist schon
spürbar und diesen 65 sagte ein ganz
besonderes und das zu verknüpfen damit
eine angelobung es ist ein besonderer
tag wir können ja gott sei dank als
einer der wenigen verbände zurückblicken
auf eine durchgehende tradition seit
1957 geben hat 15 anno dazumal die garde
als gharib atrium ernannt wurde und
seitdem eigentlich immer gerade war wir
wollen wieder zwischen banzer flieger
personen waren immer gegen somit setzt
sich eine gewisse interne tradition was
sollen das parade exerzieren angelangt
natürlich logischerweise viel viel
leichter vor dessen wohnhaus einer der
ehrengäste dieser feier ist einer der
ersten garten der tiroler karl stern als
zeitzeuge weise ja die heutige
traditionen mit entstanden sind
besonders wichtig sind ihm der stolz auf
österreich und seine kameraden
[Musik]
waren wir sehr stolz
ehrlich war für felix hat und streichelt
freien da hat er sich frei das war eine
ehre wenn man da ein recht
durch die unterschiedlichsten
repräsentativen aufgaben der
garde-soldaten ist diese einheit bis
heute etwas besonderes die umstellung
vom von
organisierten und disziplinierten
zivilen welt in die militärisch
organisiert durch gestraffte welt ist
natürlich ein erster schritt viele
burschen damit geht auch einher dass sie
sich zusammen schweißen müssen also
kameradschaft es gibt schon weit über
eine klassenkamerad schafft in der
schule hin als bezeichnend für die
bedeutung der garde ist die starke
internationale beteiligung soldaten aus
vier nationen nehmen an den
feierlichkeiten teil er steht auch für
internationale vernetzung und da ist es
eine besondere freude auch so viele
internationale gäste begrüßen zu dürfen
gerade wenn man gesehen und erlebt hat
dass
man hier mit spieler welche art und
weise
die traditionen der garde weiterzuleben
dafür treten heute 200 rekruten zur
angelobung an
[Applaus]
und dass man halt im leben ein bisschen
konsequent ist
[Musik]